sometimes I can be pretty funny hey I
can't find my phone anywhere can you
call it Oh phone where are you but for
the most part I'm just unhealthily
obsessed with things like the internet
food cats especially cyberstalking
I am like full-blown cyber stalker
status if I've met you I probably
googled you several times I become
fixated on like a specific activity or
goal or most commonly a person and then
I spend the next few days just binging
so I can devour them please tell me
you're like this - I mean I tend to
become obsessed with like actors I want
to be or people who I really admire and
I want to be friends with it's like when
you're dating someone new and they go to
the bathroom or they leave the apartment
and you just become this crazy person
that searches through all of their
or maybe that's just me and imagine
trying to stop someone pre-internet you
must have looked like a creep
so how was first doing oh yeah he's good
so I'm where where is he working now I
heard he's over in a Wayne Enterprises
and what was his address again I had it
I just lost it and I want to stop by and
say hey give me the address so just know
that if you do this you are not alone I
do it all day or they can't stop won't
step in fact I may have stalked you
normally they don't sleep on the bed so
when I do film laying down it's only
Congress but um they were all up here
today so I was like I gotta film with
them oh okay I'll stop being lame now